program which was a faculty
development program and improvement
science and I did that last year most of
the people doing that our residency
programs because of the requirement but
I was interested in the intersection of
health services research informatics and
information science those are the pools
that I play in so as fish you said I
actually don't necessarily know all of
you so I'll just tell you that I am here
in D mice upstairs on the fifth floor
I'm most I do a lot of my work in the
evidence-based Practice Center the art
funded systematic reviews but I also do
a decent amount of guidelines work for
other people and then I have an interest
in primary research in shared
decision-making and long-term care and
aging so Matt is one of the faculty
members for the Fisk program and he's
also was the VA chief resident for
quality and safety and he's currently
the improvement science lead now for the
program and the VA chief resident of
quality and safety leads that program
and he'll tell you a little bit more
about himself in just a second but I
wanted to tell you you know why I wanted
to do this I wanted to just talk a
little bit about what improvement
science is and that's mostly what Matt's
going to talk about talk about some
topics and focuses and approaches that
people are using an improvement science
and then most importantly I want to try
to start a conversation about what
improvement science and informatics can
do together both here at UA OHSU and
more generally so quickly we'll get more
into this but I wanted to show you this
because I think that these fields really
do overlap in a lot of interesting ways
so improvement science is about
strategies to improve healthcare
delivery safety and policy informatics
you all know but I wanted men to see
this is about you know how to use data
to improve health and delivery of
services and health services research
where my training is is really about how
the system works and how you can create
information to help people choose the
right care and improve
health care through delivery systems so
we are not the only people thinking
about this I just wanted to show you the
cover of one report that I came across
when I was starting to think about this
which was about how health IT could
support quality improvement in primary
care and ojun was actually one of the
case studies for this and what I thought
was interesting and this is a couple of
the key lessons learned were about that
IT you know which we all know but if you
think about how we can do this and where
it overlaps with improvement science
that health IT needs to go from just
documenting visits to actually
generating data for change and that how
it's used is really important to think
about when we're designing tools I
thought that sort of applies to what a
lot of students are doing right now so I
want to turn it over to Matt who's going
to give an intro and some overview of
things you might be interested to know
about improvement science and then dr.
fields as saris that is going to talk
about what they've been doing in family
medicine and then I have a couple of
slides from the third person who
couldn't make it today that I'll share
with you and then hopefully we'll have a
couple minutes to discuss so let's see
if I can do this
okay thank you thank you for having me
here today as the net mentioned my name
is Mattie Veronica I'm an internist by
training I completed my residency here
and internal medicine followed that up
with the year of the chief resident for
quality and safety at the VA which is
the nationally run VA program and since
then I've been serving at the OSU GME
faculty lead for improvement science
helping to run the house staff quality
and safety counsel as well as the
foundational improvement science
curriculum that Annette mentioned and
then clinically a hospitalist at the VA
the director of quality for our
hospitalist group serve on various
quality and safety committees as well at
the VA so I have a passion for
improvement and safety efforts and I'm
glad to be talking to you guys today
about this topic but as a net mentioned
I think the first thing is really to
define improvement science and you know
I went to Google to see what is Google
define improvement science as and
notably there was 700 or 760 thousand
results there digging a little bit
deeper into them if you look at the IHI
the Institute for Healthcare Improvement
their webpage on improvement science is
simply just an explanation of the PDSA
cycle there was an article in 2013 in
The Lancet called promotion of
improvement as a science they don't even
really define improvement science that
the closest they get to it is that it
draws on and aims to contribute to clear
and explicit theories of how change
happens Don Berwick former CMS youth the
one of the founders of IHI he defined it
as the applications of the approach
developed by Deming to reduce variation
in industrial processes
a little bit of a narrower definition
there interestingly you could go to
King's College and London and probably
other places around the u.s. and get a
master's degree in both implementation
and improvement science and on their
website I found it interesting because
they clearly describe what
implementation science is but only
described improvement science as the
practice of improvement and here at OHSU
we now at least within the school of
medicine tout the third science of
health care delivery of which they
incorporate improvement into so I think
what you can get the sense of is that
this is still a relatively new term as
in that pre paradigm phase where there's
not a consensus definition of what it
includes or what it includes and so my
working definition I really like yours a
net and and I think we probably overlap
pretty much here is that it's a set of
strategies and tools to improve health
care delivery systems and ensure
effective and safe patient care and it
has both relevance to the discovery of
new strategies and tools as well as the
application of them and I think the key
points here obviously being improvement
and to the systems with the ultimate
outcome of effective and safe patient
care and you can really expand that even
further into four key components which
are known as the Deming system of
profound knowledge and I believe that
pretty much all of improvement science
can be categorized into one of these
four areas appreciation of a system and
how they function building knowledge and
testing theories understanding variation
and how to respond to variation how to
interpret your data and
know whether or not that the variation
that you're seeing is either a random
variation or a significant variation
that force acting upon and then there's
the human side of change or the
psychology to change management and
pretty much everything that you do
within improvement science can be
grouped into one of these four domains
but no matter I guess like practically
speaking what you end up seeing or
hearing currently out there in the world
of improvement it's probably terms like
lien model for improvement you've
probably heard of six mix Six Sigma and
there's even a combination Lean Six
Sigma which I'm not sure I could tell
you all the differences between them
you're less likely to have heard of
things like focus PDSA or improve method
for those who have been in this field
for a while now you probably have seen
the coming and going of continuous
quality improvement but no matter which
approach you choose to use it's all
about having a system and so for those
that provide patient care this is Sir
Luke files famous painting from the
1800s here you can see the the duck is
being thoughtful and thorough we're
going to presume thorough and has a
systematic approach to his patients much
like those of you who do provide patient
care and no matter what it is that
you're your role that you feel you have
a systematic approach so for the
physician is taking a history and doing
a physical exam you'll then order maybe
some labs or imaging and then you'll try
a test of change whether it's a
medication or
a procedure of some kind and your hope
is that you then obtain a change in
health and hopefully that is a positive
change but recognizing that there are
some potential negative changes and an
improvement it's really the same formula
you hear about a story
maybe it's an error maybe it's that
you're not meeting a certain metric or
you just want to improve care in a
certain area you go to see it in action
to understand the process better you
perform your exam you'll maybe collect
some data
maybe it's chart reviews or patient data
perhaps it's the literature and seeing
what is the best evidence that we have
on this and you'll design a test of
change all with the hope that you're
going to provide a change to the system
of care delivery and again hopefully
it's a positive one and if you believe
this Paul but all didn't quote that
every system is perfectly designed to
get the results that it get then you
will buy into the notion that having a
systematic approach to changing the
system will then prevent those errors
from reaching the patient or improve the
quality of care that we deliver so why
is improvement science important well
hopefully if that didn't get you for
those that are physicians you know we
took a Hippocratic oath and I think most
doctors probably think of that as a very
singular Act I won't harm the patient
but I'm of the belief that if we
continue to allow systems to harm
patients without trying to improve them
that we're probably not holding up to
that oh you know there's the idealism of
course I want to improve my work
and improve the care that I want to
provide but I think the realities can
sometimes set in that there's that
doesn't happen or those that you know
believe that the way that they do things
is the best way or the right way but I
think the real reason why this gets
increasingly talked about and probably
what you guys are feeling is the
pressure pressure from prospective
students or the current student to say I
want to learn more about this your
payers whether it's CMS or insurance
groups that want to provide only
value-based payment various regulators
Jayco comes in a wide ricans into the VA
and accreditors and for education as
well so ACGME or whichever professional
body or accrediting body that you have
to respond to is demanding that this is
now taught and learned and so hopefully
you can get a sense that the time really
to learn about improvement science and
start participating in some of these
activities it's really now and I might
even argue yesterday so some of the
efforts that are going on here at OHSU
for faculty training we are wrapping up
our second year of the fisk program
which is an all nine session curriculum
designed to teach both basics of
improvement science the foundational
knowledge as well as the curriculum
development and pedagogy and try to pair
the two of them together to then create
curricula to bring for the for those
that attend will then bring that
curriculum
to their various programs mostly we've
had as a net mentioned residency program
from GME because that's where our
funding stream has come from but we've
also had a net here representing demise
we've had nursing doctrinal doctoral
nursing program representatives and
we've had several ume undergraduate
medical education representatives as
well for residency for training the
residents not only are we getting the
outcomes from the FISC program and new
improvement science curriculums being
taught to the residents we also have the
OHSU House staff quality and safety
council or OHSU HQ SC and you can check
out their website at Hsu HQ SC org and
this is a resident run group which I
helped to I'm a faculty advisor and lead
for the groove that is focused on
[Music]
education for the residents and
partnering with hospital administration
to try to bridge that gap between
education and hospital function to have
this group be in charge of improvement
projects across the institution so what
if you wanted to if you had further
interest in improvement what are some of
the things that you could be doing today
o Hsu has the OHSU performance
excellence system or OPEX which you may
have heard of before they offer various
courses which you can sign up for online
if you go through the o2 website for
those of you that may be at the VA you
can sign up for lean belt training they
have the various colors yellow and green
and black belts to signify the level of
forty's and those are the things that
are recognized nationwide as a
certificate the IHI has open schools an
excellent resource for those that like
online modules and perhaps have limited
time you can do these at your own
leisure and if you signed up through
your dot edu email address they're free
you just have to make sure you use a dot
edu email there's a great harvardx
Harvard EDX massive open online course
which has already just completed for the
spring but if you went to the edx.org
website and signed up for notifications
they'll usually run it again in the fall
and for those that like the book and the
self-guided adventure I would highly
recommend the improvement guide which
was my my first foray into learning
about this and you can probably find
that on Amazon for some $25 or $30 or so
so hopefully it is becoming increasingly
recognized the importance of providing
the education for improvement science
because of all the various pressures
that we are seeing from outside from
external and internal sources and I'm
hoping we can kick start the
conversation today on what else we can
do with the demise program to provide
some of that thank you
I had a question I'll start identify
okay started and that is you mentioned
effectiveness and safety in the
definition I'm wondering where I'll use
the word efficiency but what I really
mean is dollars
where does dollars billion in regards to
yeah yeah I took out my one slide that I
had the various frameworks for
measurement of effectiveness so thank
you for bringing that up and calling
that out so that certainly is in there
and is a personal working definition and
it probably should be in there but I
look to the IHI who has a Triple Aim and
now even the quadruple aim and yeah
okay I need to unhide this first so so
here's the Triple Aim in the quadruple
aim which were developed by Don Burwick
and I achai they do have the cost per
capita and they're the quadruple aim
incorporates the provider and their
experience in their level of
satisfaction
the alternative framework that's most
popularly used is one that was
popularized by the Institute of Medicine
back in 2001 as their follow-up to the
quality chasm and here they have their
six domains of measurement for care so
is that anti respond during what you
thought improvement science included
those broader issues or not I I do yeah
a great question I think it's the
implementation science I think of as a
sort of the application of what I've
learned from improvement science at a
much larger scale so personally I don't
function I don't have the background of
the implementation science because I see
it as I think of a great example would
be the Michigan central line infections
which is a popular story and so it is it
tends to be on a much larger scale
beyond the single site or even two or
three single sites but addressing how do
you take what its successful in one
hospital setting and developing it so
that it's successful in many other
hospitals
settings so they do go hand in hand and
probably for this master's degree it
makes sense to combine both of them yeah
I think that's a point well taken I'm
not sure if you have any additional
thoughts but funny thing is you were
asking the question I was I was thinking
about I was thinking about the concept
that the ankle bone is connected to the
knee bone and yet we have ankle
specialists we have me to areas I'm a
family doc I'm actually wondering why
the patient injured themselves to begin
with and and the concept that that I'm a
generalist okay and so what you're
really describing is what's the right
level of specificity that you want to
get to I don't know if there's a right
answer to that question I think there
are needs probably across the board
there's a need for the generalists and
the family doc and there's a need for
the orthopedic specialist who's who does
the knee and an or please keep it
orthopedic specialist does the ankle
it's okay so I think it really depends
on what your demand is and what the
needs are of the community
yeah so how do we change the culture of
the practicing providers from my
experience I found that you have to
demonstrate to the providers that
there's value in change it can often be
so hard for somebody to recognize that
what their scope is in the larger field
of their clinic and it can be hard for
them having that narrow focus and that
narrow world view of how they function
to understand the value to the clinic as
a whole or even the value to the patient
or whatever their ever their care
setting is so finding an effective way
to communicate the value through usually
done through good stories and then data
to back up the story is going to be the
way that most people respond
some people will respond to Authority
and say because you know because the you
know this being said this is important
we're going to do it so those I think
are the three telling a good story
having data to support the need for
change and
having the support at least you need to
support the buy-in of leadership and so
they're going to go to three main
components operationalizing that is a
little bit harder and it's a long term
process and I think even just from my
time here I've seen loss of resistance
that has started to melt away so Shannon
asked my question but I have a new one
now what's the evidence that this work
is there strong evidence I know it's a
huge bet what work improvement science
doesn't work as compared to say
continuous quality improvement or any of
the other buzzwords I think they are all
are all buzzwords I don't think it
matters what you call it it's about the
process that matters and I think there's
tremendous evidence in I'll say the
manufacturing world around this and
we're just beginning to scratch the
surface as it relates to the health
health community and and the medical
system overall but but when you have
stories because we do have stories here
at OHSU where we've made big differences
in outcomes for our patients that that
it really matters so yeah I think I
think there's tremendous evidence for it
and I will have argue that there is a
larger preponderance of evidence to to
make change rather than to do nothing at
all and I don't think anybody in here
would say that that doing nothing is an
acceptable answer and so my major
argument would be then if you need to
make change because we've decided that
doing nothing is not an option then
having a systematic approach will only
increase your época see
one one last question and it kind of
ties in to you talked about the changing
culture and one of the ways is to
demonstrate value and to demonstrate
that what you're going to do is wolf is
going to work button all you may not
only need but what can happen is that if
you implement something and it doesn't
work that can be the mo that groups and
providers can use to say this doesn't
work so why should we do it and in the
prayer and in the setting of failure in
the in the face of failure how do you
continue to motivate people to say that
the process is important even if we find
failure that's great on a theoretical
sitting in a meeting but when you're
talking about providers interacting with
their patients that's much harder to
commit and so just kind of interested on
how do you deal in implementations that
do fail and to continue to motivate them
to state this fail to let's work on the
next project because that I would argue
that that learning something is never a
failure so you may do something and it
may not work but the very fact of
learning that it doesn't work is
actually value in it of itself and if
you can get the culture to believe that
then you're in good shape but you're
right that you can't fail to improve
every single time if you never improve
you're you're never you're never going
to get there but if you if you learn
some negative things in the in the in
the way that's that's what science is
all about including improvement science
yeah
Edison light bulb yeah right I'm going
to take oversight okay thank you very
much so it's a great honor to be here
I've gotten to interact with Vishnu on
on working to get fellows it's at ocean
for those who don't know ocean ocean is
a non-for-profit company housed in the
downpour downtown Portland that places
electronic health records and other
technology tools in federally qualified
health centers and rural health centers
throughout the country and as such we
have about 20 million people on that
electronic health record system more
broadly and therefore a single data
warehouse that houses that and from
which we can do significant
research and scholarly pursuits to
actually learn what works and what
doesn't work so that's my role as CMO is
to try to develop tools as it relates to
data to help improve the care of
patients we have two of the fellows that
have been there already and I their
other fellows in the room you'll
eventually get there look forward to it
I'm the former vice chair of family
medicine here I am professor emeritus
which means that I get to say things and
nobody cares what it is anymore which is
good and so today what I want to do is
share with you a story and maybe tell
you a little bit about how we developed
our culture and what I would like you to
do is to think about your own
environment this is this is our story
but immediately start to think about
what does it mean for you if you're a
clinician think about your what you do
clinically you're not a clinician you
fit somewhere in the system figure out
where you fit because this is a team
sport this is not about what I do it's
about what we do and so as I go through
this feel free to interrupt me challenge
anything that I have to say I might be
wrong okay all right so this is a
hypothesis the healthcare system is
changing might be might not be I don't
know they're voting right now you know
God knows the way that success is
measured is changing the way that
success is change is measured is
changing the way that we interact with
the healthcare system is changing and
the we can be clinicians staff patients
everything is changing is the hypothesis
and then but and this is I think really
important to all of us who work in
healthcare and I think it goes to why in
health care making these changes is more
difficult it's about individual patients
and we all are unique snowflakes in our
own way okay as patients we're all
unique snowflakes
and so the fact that the patient
clinician relationship is still the
foundation of providing care to patients
that's my hypothesis but that's still
there okay
maybe changing it is changing I would
say but but this is part of what we're
doing so in terms of evolution we're
focusing on outcomes decreasing costs
the patient experience and the clinician
experience these are this is the
quadruple aim just put in a different
way that you just heard about this I
said this is evolution you know being
able to focus on outcomes is totally
driven by the ability to have data we
didn't we weren't really able to focus
on outcomes because we didn't have data
and when we went live here at OHSU in
2005 on epic it was in some ways really
the first time that we had the
opportunity to get data out of the
system we can put as much data into the
system as we want but unless we get data
out then it's worthless
and so this is the the electronic health
record and our abilities to have data
warehouses has really changed our
ability to do this work this improvement
science work so where the health system
is going new payment models new ways to
incentivize the system of care so if you
are around or not been around the health
care system
we've been driven by a fee-for-service
methodology for probably 40 to 50 years
now okay maybe longer depending on how
you want to think about it
now we are starting to move towards
population health criterias so in other
words how is a group of patients doing
as opposed to any individual patient and
on another hand we're doing pay for
performance which is how well am i doing
taking care of patients we'll talk about
some of the pluses and minuses of that
so as you change the payment structure
the incentives are changing my incentive
is a clinician has has changed some over
time as the payment model has changed so
about 20% of my payment comes in in the
form of what's called capitation or or
per person payments now for those of you
that are old enough to remember managed
care in the late 80s and 90s it's the
same idea but in the 80s and 90s we
didn't actually have data about how we
were doing taking care of those
populations now we actually have the
data makes a big difference so if if the
delivery census system changes how will
quality change and this is about
aligning metrics so if you're going to
you know incentivize people you need to
make sure that the things you're
measuring actually reflect what you're
trying to accomplish and so this is a
this is a lot of what we're doing right
now in healthcare and it's very
controversial one of the things that has
driven this is actually be ACA this is a
map of those that have done ACA
expansion and those that haven't in the
gold and the states that have moved in
this direction are moving much more
towards a data-driven care because again
they're they're looking at populations
it has led to a much greater level of
administrative burden to the practices I
want to acknowledge that there's
administrative burden to this practice
but is the the juice worth the squeeze
if you will and and so you know we're
trying to figure that out and I'm going
to give you some ideas about that this
is the building blocks of effective
patient-centered medical homes that was
described
by bodenheimer you say well wait a
minute I'm not in primary care or you
know this does not in the health care
doesn't matter to me actually it does
because it actually was discussed the
number one thing here is an engaged
leadership okay if you don't have an
engaged leadership you're not going to
be able to drive that cultural process
but down here on the on the bottom are
engaged leadership data-driven
improvement impalement is about knowing
who your patients are knowing who your
patients are so you know if you work in
a in a pulmonology clinic you have to
decide who am I responsible for because
if I'm responsible for them then there
are some things that I probably should
be measured about and and get that
information so impediment matters and
then the reality that this is a team
sport that I already mentioned and that
the outcome is not dependent on the
clinician which as a clinician is both
freeing and for many clinician is scary
okay so one of the things that you run
into in terms of resistance is I don't
want to give up my control of what
happens to patients all right and so
that's part of what we have to get past
if we're going to be successful with
this this is probably the most important
slide that I that I have in this deck
when you how many of you guys have
worked in a clinical environment okay
so when you go in somebody tells you how
to do the work right you get trained and
when you get trained you then go and you
do it I don't care what it is but you go
do it
in this case patient care from that
we're beginning to get data back so
we've done the patient care we're
getting the data back and then you
create an improvement strategy this is
the same idea of the slides that you've
already seen but then you do plan do
study act process maybe just a stud
process I don't know
and then and then you have to redesign
and then you retrain to that design so
what we all need to get you know a
cultural phenomenon about is that things
change people hate change in general
okay we like it the way it is and and
that's just part of the reality but if
we do this process then you get quality
and improvement in patient's health and
for me that's all that I really care
about
I want patients help to improve all
right so when you get data it's really
seductive to define things as being good
or bad or people as being good or bad
and you really need to always ask the
question why so in my practice for
instance and we're giving data to our
clinicians on an ongoing basis and
somebody is doing quotes better on the
metrics than somebody else
the first question should be why are
they doing better is there something in
their workflow that's different than the
other people and that's why is there
something different in the substrate ie
the patient's that they have that make
it different for them I don't know what
the answer is but if you go into this
process in a punitive fashion it's one
of the fastest ways to not allow that
cultural shift to occur okay now that
means in our department we have not tied
any of our data to compensation so none
of our data about about quality of care
is tied to compensation that was a
choice that we made because we wanted
people to do it quotes for the right
reasons
ie improved the health of patients it
was never a goal to have clinicians make
more money that was not our mission okay
and is not our mission our mission is to
improve health so one of the choices
that you have to make is how closely
aligned you make the payments
thumbs to to the metrics just something
to think about this is really important
in today's world because if payers are
paying you based on performance then one
of the things that you run a risk of is
for people to make choices about how to
maximize that revenue that hurts
patients example you all are diabetics
let's say this group over here are
really really tough diabetics okay
really tough you're tough because you
don't take your medicines you're tough
because you have really significant
disease you're tough because you drink
alcohol
you're tough okay this group is perfect
okay
this group is you know just very simple
which patients do I want to take care of
if my revenue is based on the data okay
I want that group good luck to all of
you okay that is actually part of what's
happening in the vote today guys watch
it watch it it's happening today right
now in order to gain and buy-in from the
clinicians to staff within the
healthcare system about measurement and
performance it is critical that there be
a CO accurate impoundment I talked about
that who are my patients is the first
questions so that is because of
accountability and responsibility for
the care so that means that any patient
had in this in our world the definition
is any patient who has me listed as a
PCP and has been seen in the clinic in
the last at least once in the last three
years is mine okay and our patients in
the clinic is any of those who have any
of us listed as a PCP and then seen the
last three years we made that up okay
now there is some national discussion
about what it means but in many clinics
it's one year in mid some clinics it's
two years you could make a difference
depending on specialty
okay we're continuity providers so we
all we value the concept of continuity
so if just because you came and saw me
for
a well a well adult care three years ago
I consider you still my patient because
I'm responsible for the health
maintenance that might happen along the
way okay that makes sense so there you
go then why are we seeing our patients
so who are we seeing who are my patients
and then why are we seeing them and
that's driven by the problem list the
visit diagnosis procedures that we do
and then even just reasons for phone
calls and things like that so the first
question is who are my patients the
second question is why am I seeing them
and so my diabetic patients are any
patients that which I'm listed as a PCP
and the patient has been seen in the
last three years in the clinic and has a
diabetic related icd-10 diagnosis on the
problem list that's our definition all
right so definitions matter and when
you're doing definitions and you're
going to give data to people to use the
first thing you need to do is actually
run the definition by them you don't get
to tell people what the definition is
you have to take a cut at it give it to
them and get buy-in that's part of the
cultural shift that has to happen they
have to own these metrics if they're not
your metrics they're your metrics okay
and as long as things are being done to
us by governments federal or state by
payers then the clinicians will not buy
and the and the clinics will not buy
health systems will not buy all right
and then how well are we doing caring
for our patients notice this is really
the question that you all care about but
you don't get there until you know who
you're taking care of and why you're
taking care of them you can't get to the
how well until you get there so you can
have what are called process indicators
and outcome indicators you guys familiar
with those terms at all
yes no maybe sometimes so if you all are
then I won't waste too much time on it
but but
process indicators means did I do the
right thing to the right patient at the
right time okay an example flu shots
okay or any other immunization I'm
supposed to give you the right
immunization at the right time to the
right people that make sense
versus outcome indicators I'm supposed
to measure hemoglobin a1cs and diabetics
but what the number is is the outcome
you could say okay some people would
define that as an outcome so if the out
if the hemoglobin a1c is bad am I
responsible for that and the answer is
maybe but the challenge that you have to
think about is whether or not you're
going to tie payment associated with
this because if you're going to tie
payment then again these people will
receive no care from me okay because for
whatever reason even if I screwed up
okay if I can't get that hemoglobin a1c
down below nine then I don't want that
patient in my practice it's really
simple I want all you guys you guys are
great okay and so that's what that were
that's what we're watching okay and what
all of you need to watch in health care
about whether or not you're asking me to
do things or asking the system to do
things that they actually have control
of okay and we would we would argue in
our practice that we don't have really
good control of the hemoglobin a1c that
doesn't mean that it's not a good goal
it doesn't mean it shouldn't be measured
it just means that time I payment to it
is not wise okay in terms of moral
hazard hazard so how well am i doing for
caring for my patients how well are we
doing caring for our patients these are
these really depend on what mu what
level in the organization we're going to
look at so we can look at it what I call
an organizational level which is our
entire department we can look at a
specific clinic we can look at a team
within the clinic and/or we can look at
me
okay and so you can decide and in our
place we give them all because it all
matters we want to see whether or not
there are four teams there are four
teams in our clinic down at South
Waterfront we want to see if one of the
teams is doing something different than
the other and why right the question is
why
so then we also care about what's going
on South Waterfront but we care what's
going on at Scappoose Richmond and
Gabriel Park just as much and so they
get there and then maybe one of the
clinics is doing better okay
and ultimately we compare what LHS you
family medicine is doing against the
internists who we also do some reporting
for and they do some reporting of their
own but we care about what the interests
are doing because we're doing kind of
the same thing we care and we look at
this nationally - of what's going on
okay so who we're measuring and you know
who we're comparing ourselves to we want
actionable information and populations
are about systems of care so this was
about you know how to build systems and
I said everybody is a snowflake and that
is true but they are all snowflakes okay
so you want to know how to take care of
snowflakes the best you can but you have
to be able to individualize it to some
degree because you're all individual
snowflakes unique snowflakes all right
this is the slide that I am most proud
of in in my twenty thirty thirty two
years got it got passed the another
decade thirty two years of being here
okay this is a bunch of different
indicators and all that you need to be
aware of is that they're getting better
okay they're going the right direction
and you don't need to read them but what
this means is actually people's lives
okay this is actually people's lives we
know that if people's hemoglobin a1c is
under better control that they have less
complication are less likely to die okay
we know that if we give Pneumovax to the
elderly patient or those with high risks
that if we do that less of them die okay
so these are people's lives and so this
demonstrates that we have a system of
care within our practices it's not just
about one indicator so the idea being
that that if you choose one of these you
need to then think about what the
standardized aspects of that process are
that you can then translate across
multiple venues because if you don't
what happens is you focus on Pneumovax
it gets really good at the same time
that hypertension control goes down
through the floor so that makes sense
you've got to build a system that does
more than one thing at one time all
right so that's a that's a really
important thing all right
so obtained so what is successfully
under getting a true understanding of
the quality of care the cost of care and
most importantly the outcomes of care
outcomes being defined as patients
health not a lab test okay that's it yep
go ahead okay answer why she's doing
that that's Russia my name um my
question is kind of around the idea of
outcomes and patient's health because I
think that can be difficult to define
sometimes and in this case what I'm
really asking is how do you think to
bridge the gap or balance something like
what we can might consider to be an
objectively good patient outcomes such
as you know take back pain is one of the
up difficult ones where your back pain
gets better and then also balance that
with
what is the patient level of
satisfaction with the experience of
healthcare that they had and so you know
not revenue any particular piece of data
here but to say like back surgery versus
Novak sir yes
maybe there's no difference in the
amount of functional back pain or
ability of people to walk or level of
disability after the you know people who
didn't have surgery or they did but
whether maybe the people who did have
surgery felt like they got a more kind
of yeah more treatment I got guys early
and and how do you balance that idea in
terms of like okay here we've got like
quality of life adjusted years yeah here
we've got like just I'm happier yep
so the interesting thing is that we
actually know from research that when we
ask a patient how do you feel that that
actually is a the incredible predictor
of health that the likely is that
they're going to hospitalized or die
okay and so knowing how people feel
about their health is really really
important what you're describing though
I'm going to say is is some of that
cultural stuff about education so it's
about being willing it is much easier
for me to order an MRI of the back than
it is to sit down and describe to them
why it's important not to do that okay
it takes it's much I can do that in with
epic man I can just pop that baby out
and guess what in the current system
I'm incentivized to do that okay because
this building is built on MRIs all right
and so let's do more all right but the
problem is that we're going to go broke
as a health care system and that's why
it's changing I'm sorry that the system
is changing and so we're also beginning
to get paid for the conversation a
little bit more okay and that's part of
the incentives changing for us I
actually have time to do that so very
quickly I want to mention one thing and
maybe we'll do a session next year but
originally I'd hoped that Elizabeth
Crabtree could be here as well but I
just want to point out she is faculty
and demised some a lot of you probably
not her yet because she's very busy
because her main position is as the
director of clinical integration and
evidence-based medicine and I just
wanted to point out that how that's
connected to all the improvements some
of which is through the value-based care
in the payment but this is something
that's happening here at OHSU and she
has a presentation that we can have her
come due but I want to point out that
one of the things they're doing is a
course interprofessional course and just
make sure that you're aware of her so in
a couple of minutes we have left the
main thing that I was interested in
starting to get you all to think about
and why I wanted to do this Grand Rounds
was you know like I said I I'm
interested in this and I went through
the FISC program not because he might
have the residency but because I was
sort of interested in what they were
teaching faculty and what residents are
doing but also I'm thinking about are
there bridges between what de maiz
faculty and students want to do and the
improvement science efforts in the
hospital and in other departments and
divisions so I'm just in a couple
seconds we have left if you know I'm
looking for ideas on you know is this
something that should fit in D my
somewhere and if so where how should we
explicitly address it in classes does it
fit with our research agenda or with our
own policies and practice and I'm really
interesting things the reason I was
impressed with dr. fields and he didn't
say this is family medicine has invested
a huge amount of time money and
expertise they hire probably more
analysts than any other department so
they actually like hire people that come
out of our types of programs and they
actually do a lot of that analysis now
for other departments which is kind of
and that's a system he built and so I
know we're like at the end but if
anybody does want either a have a
comment or an idea of how we could sort
of connect things and then be you
hopefully we can continue this going
forward
you know I get in you mentioned the
difference between documenting a visit
and generating data for change and I
think that's really important and I
think that's kind of the shift we're
seeing informatics we're like a decade
15 years ago is all about implementing
systems and learning how to do that well
I'm getting over the adoption curve
we're now we're more into analytics I
see it totally being complementary I
would argue for interweaving it in every
single class that's possible especially
on the clinical side dr. Mel hands class
would be a great place to introduce it
but it wouldn't be though I think it
could be an overarching themes that
might fit with many classes Karen yes so
right now there are a couple of new
announcements from arc that are specific
to clinic to clinical decision support
and implementing current for new things
and disseminating them I mean it feels
to me like we're going to need a partner
to do this yeah and I hope arc still is
an opening accounted for absolutely
taking this course and listening to what
all these what family medicine has been
doing long before Fisk started and then
what some of the newer depart the
departments who are coming into it
because now they have to but they're
really very engaged it was a really
interesting experience so you know the
residency programs have to do this for a
certification but the people who are
trying to design it really want to do it
well I think I was pretty impressed and
you know it seemed like there could be
more connections between be my students
and those programs in and/or demise
faculty and faculty wanting to do more
long term projects that could fall under
you know the rubric between what's
research and what's improvement science
I mean they're both important than I
think those should fit together too but
that's a whole other discussion we could
have so I would like to do something
useful in this area and I don't know
what it is so I was hoping to use this
as a way to
start to get some ideas is it you know
some resources to add some things into
some classes isn't working with some
students who are interested in this and
going through people like Matt or Scott
to find connections to build projects
that build these bridges and so I know
we're done so I'll just these were just
you know just closing you know the
standard you can't improve what you
can't measure but I'd argue as much as
measuring its monitoring and
understanding it and then we talked
about how you don't like change but the
Winston Churchill quote is to prove is
to change and to be perfect is to change
often and that's essentially what we're
working on so maybe this is something
with some that we can continue next year
but I wanted to at least get it started
so thank you all for coming today and
thank the people who are doing is
joining us remotely and any last
question I think we're at time so I
don't want to keep make people late I'm
happy to stick around either inside or
outside dad's answer any questions that
people might have this is really
exciting work and so the stuff you're
learning actually matters and you know
that was right we hire people in the
department that do this work but but so
do other departments here that are doing
this well and so it's a it's a
burgeoning area that's for sure as does
the VA - absolutely absolutely yeah
thanks sure can you do a PDF of it yeah
thank you
yes ma'am so got to go to the Senate
when does the money get with their power
yeah not until the Congressional Budget
Office does its assessment which it
hasn't they passed that without knowing
what is going lost yeah well right now
they did at least until September
because they got a huge funding and the
in the in the Budget Reconciliation
which goes through September there's two
billion additional dollar additional
dollars or NIH and researcher yeah
understand the stupid friends are
cleaning confidence in yourself
la costly time to go to work